this episode was made possible by
dashlane protect your valuable data from
prying eyes with a free account from
dashlane in a recent episode we looked
at past predictions of the future they
got some things right and other things
very wrong and that was only over the
course of less than a century in this
episode we're going to look at what we
think the future will be like over the
next thousand years while it's very
difficult if not impossible to
accurately predict the far future we
have developed better tools to be more
precise in our predictions than the
people of the past just to be safe we'll
look at both the positive and negative
possibilities of the next thousand years
let's start with a big one humans
becoming an interplanetary species with
government organizations like NASA and
private companies like SpaceX aiming to
land humans on Mars by the mid 2030s at
the very latest it stands to reason that
our species could have fully colonized
the red planet and the moon by the Year
3018 a thousand years is a very long
time but according to some scientists
not nearly long enough to create a
breathable atmosphere on Mars so while
we could start the long terraforming
process long before 3018 humans on Mars
would still have to wear protective
suits and live an indoor lifestyle for
the next several thousand years of
course that's based on our current
technology we may discover some new way
to terraform barren planets more quickly
but at the very least will likely have
giant bio domes where humans can walk
around without their suits and live a
fairly normal life far from Earth
speaking of Earth the main reason we'll
have left our home planet is because
statistically speaking it's only a
matter of time until some natural
disaster or man-made Cataclysm ends our
species for good
if the entirety of humanity lived on
earth when a planet killing asteroid
came knocking game over if however we
managed to become a spacefaring
civilization before that point our
future would be secure
Mars wouldn't be the only planet we
could colonize either Venus as unlivable
as its surface is has a relatively
temperate climate above the clouds
we could easily establish floating cloud
cities that could drift around the
planet on the wind while scientists of
the future worked on terraforming the
surface some experts think that Venus is
an even more promising target for
colonization than Mars so it stands to
reason that by the year thirty eighteen
we could have thriving colonies on both
planets the more footholds we have away
from Earth the greater the likelihood of
our survival as a species back on earth
there are a few possibilities for the
next
years right now we're destroying the
earth at an alarming rate polluting the
ocean and the air killing hundreds of
plant and animal species as we destroy
their homes wrecking ecosystems and the
ozone layer if we don't get our act
together runaway climate change could
cause apocalypse level natural disasters
the likes of which we've never seen even
today we're beginning to see the
negative effects scientists have been
predicting for decades out-of-control
wildfires rising sea levels melting
IceCaps widespread animal extinctions
and global temperature rise if we
continue to be poor stewards of the
planet for the next hundred years
life on Earth may become unsustainable
if however we change direction soon and
start implementing new greener
technology and stop our destructive
consumerist practices we have a chance
to leave the earth a better place for
the people of the future at our current
rates of consumption all of the planet's
fossil fuels will be completely depleted
in less than a hundred and ten years if
we don't implement alternative energy
sources before then our civilization is
in big trouble
scientists predict that solar power
could produce a third of our necessary
energy by 2060 with added help from wind
and geothermal we could be well on our
way to a hundred percent renewable
energy by 2100 this would benefit not
only humans but every living thing on
earth as our carbon footprint would be
greatly reduced with the threat of
runaway climate change defeated we could
set our sights on amazing new
technologies to improve our lives
one such advancement we'll probably see
is the merging of man and machine this
idea is called transhumanism and could
give us abilities never before possible
by 2060 computers should be able to
perform most tasks as well as or better
than humans so to keep up will either
need to set up a labor force comprised
entirely of machines or find a way to
integrate with them many experts suspect
that within the next hundred years we'll
be able to augment our natural bodies
with complex technology visual overlays
for entertainment and information direct
download to our brains replacement of
weak or disabled body parts with
fabricated replicas this could extend
our lives provide a greater standard of
living and allow humans to become more
intelligent more physically capable and
more productive however as with every
new breakthrough there could be
unforeseen consequences if we begin to
augment our brains with this kind of
technology we could become susceptible
to hackers accessing our information or
worse gaining control of our motor
functions bodies could reject inorganic
replacement parts or
cause health problems down the line or
there could be no issues at all on the
individual level but since people would
live longer the earth could quickly
become overpopulated as artificial
intelligence becomes more sophisticated
we could end up either in an automated
utopia where humans are free to pursue
whatever they choose or we could find
ourselves no longer at the top of the
food chain outpaced by AI that far
surpasses our intelligence and abilities
then there's the possibility that we
could have everything we ever wanted
media communication games a whole
virtual life without ever having to
leave home social skills could suffer
and we might end up with a society of
humans unable or unwilling to interact
in person of course these are fears that
crop up every time a new technology is
developed sure we have people addicted
to TV or video games or smartphones but
it's not the majority of society and we
have no reason to believe that would be
different in the future in terms of
culture the populations of Earth will be
much more connected and if we manage to
survive another thousand years we'll
likely be much more peaceful than we are
today world religions will likely be
very different from their current forms
and many speculate that religion may no
longer play a central role in society
travel between countries will be quick
and easy with new modes of
transportation taking much less time
than the conventional methods of today
there will likely be fewer languages or
combinations of current languages making
it easier for people from around the
world to communicate depending on how
well we cooperate with each other we
could very well see a global currency or
if we become a multiplanetary species a
galactic currency in a society where the
majority of labor is handled by machines
the arts could flourish and we could
enjoy a new renaissance of literature
music film the fine arts and technology
with this new technology and the time to
pursue humanitarian endeavors we could
possibly end world hunger homelessness
and disease and some even speculate that
eventually we might be able to upload
our consciousness into computers and
defeat death itself this is all
completely feasible within the next
thousand years but it's impossible to
predict which path humanity will take
will we be able to overcome our selfish
nature and work towards a better future
for the generations to come will we
become an interplanetary species in time
will humans even exist in 1,000 years
we'll just have to wait and see while we
may not have to worry about people
hacking our brains just yet we do have
to worry about keeping our personal data
secure with the new and improved
dashlane it's easier than ever
to stay safe online - Lane is a free
super secure way to protect your
identity keep track of all your
passwords in one place and even autofill
login fields for each account it uses a
u.s. patented local encryption storage
system that can only be accessed by the
user
a couple awesome new features they
recently added is offering a VPN and
dark web monitoring to actively protect
your identity the VPN encrypts your data
on unsecure connections to keep your
information safe and private dark web
monitoring is just as awesome as it
sounds it lets you monitor up to five
email accounts and get detailed security
alerts if any personal information is
found on the dark web
this service scans more than 12 billion
records attached to hacks and data
breaches with almost a million new
records added every day
one thing that hasn't changed with the
new dashlane is how easy it is to handle
all your passwords if you do have the
same password everywhere and you don't
want to deal with going to each
individual website and going through all
the steps of changing your password each
time you can just press one button in
the dashlane app and it does it for you
automatically super quick super secure
and you don't have to worry about
remembering a bunch of different
passwords because dashlane takes care of
it for you you can also save other
autofill options and sensitive documents
like software licenses your credit card
details or your shipping address and
populate those fields when needed the
free version of dashlane lets you store
up to 50 passwords autofill login fields
and lots more but if you upgrade to a
premium account for just 5 bucks a month
you get even more cool features like the
VPN and dark web monitoring fans of
second thought can get a 30-day free
trial of dashlane premium by following
the link below or use the code second
thought to get a 10% discount on your
premium subscription it's available for
Mac PC iOS and Android so whether you go
for the free or premium account I can't
recommend dashlane highly enough so to
support the channel and secure your
valuable data check out - Lane at the
link below
you